bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire en 45 minutes avec bonjean
katia bonjour michael et c'est une
semaine marquée par une série de bugs du
gouvernement sur le sujet crucial des
impôts à un mois des élections
régionales des retraités ont vu leurs
impôts locaux exploser le gouvernement a
voulu rectifier le tir en appelant
certains contribuables à ne pas payer ce
qu'il devait manuel valls alors c'est le
chantier du code du travail sa réforme
devrait prendre au moins deux ans un
premier projet de loi est attendu avant
l'été 2016 la droite parle de réforme
est le premier celui de révolution et
puis on reviendra sur une audition sous
tension au parlement députés et
sénateurs ont entendu le pdg d'air
france puis les représentants de
l'intersyndicale sur les plans
d'économies du groupe pour améliorer la
compétitivité de la compagnie
l'autre invité cette semaine luc chatel
bonjour bonjour réputé les républicains
de haute-marne ancien ministre
conseiller politique de nicolas sarkozy
vous connaissez la petite tradition de
cette émission le portrait est dressé
par vos collègues parlementaires
vous allez regarder et puis vous
réagissez juste après direct rend
intelligent
homme de conviction luc chatel est
quelqu'un de très intelligent et de
courageux il l'a montré quand il était
ministre de l'éducation nationale je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
d'idées qui a des convictions et qui
sait les faire partager
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
malheureusement à l'époque n'a pas fait
de son ministère une priorité dans le
cadre du gouvernement sarkozy fillon
c'est quelqu'un de très sérieux de très
travailleur et qui a pour moi un bel
avenir devant lui c'est un homme solide
qui ne parle pas pour ne rien dire et
qui est toujours d'une très grande
courtoisie
je dirais un collègue très agréable ce
que j'appellerai à droite conservatrice
et ne voyons pas forcément l'intérêt
public l'intérêt général l'avenir de la
jeunesse c'est un un courant de l'ump
qui fait honneur à la république et qui
mérite lui de porter le nom de
république
alors voilà ça c'est plutôt pas mal pour
vous j'ai noté aussi quand même droite
pour faire ma tête mais je note surtout
ministre de l'éducation nationale à jour
ministre de l'éducation nationale
toujours c'est ça colle à la peau
quelque part ça marque
évidemment ça marque à vie presque ce
passage ans à l'éducation nationale mais
si cette évidence et c'est un nid
d'abord c'est un immense honneur d'être
ministre et nicolas sarkozy nous disait
souvent cela quand j'avais qui se
plaignait qui était fatigué il y en a
marre c'est dur tu es m'attendais ou
combien de temps serez vous bénisse dans
votre vie combien de personnes
aimeraient être à votre place c'est un
honneur d'être ministre d'abord ensuite
mise l'éducation nationale c'est sans
doute l'un des plus beaux ministère vous
occupez de l'avenir du pays la jeunesse
c'est très difficile mine gérée un
million de fonctionnaires vous préparer
l'avenir donc c'est fantastique donc ça
évidemment que ça vous marque mini 5 en
or on sort on ne sort pas indifférent de
ce ministère mini c'est encore un sens
aujourd'hui quand on voit qu'il ya
certains ministres qui quittent le
gouvernement pour être
maire d'une grande ville ou qui
préfèrent aller aux élections régionales
plutôt que d'aller peut-être plus tard
dans un grand ministère
c'est encore un sens il ya deux
questions est ce que vous dites y'a la
première est ce que ces nobles de
vouloir être présent de région plutôt
que comme ministre et autres bien sûr
est de plus en plus nous nous serons
dans une une démocratie a peut-être plus
de poids moi je suis un décentralisateur
dont je suis favorable à ce que les
régions prennent du poids politique donc
ça c'est très respectable par contre la
première partie d'autres questions peut
faire référence à des déclarations que
j'ai lu ici ou là dans toutes les tous
les bords politiques gardien mais ça
sert pas ça sert plus à rien mais c'est
faux bon allez expliquer aux français
que finalement on sert à rien au matin
on arrête tout moi je suis désolé j'ai
eu le sentiment de par petits bouts
chaque jour
fermez bien sûr bien sûr heureusement
allez on déroule le fil de l'actualité
avec lundi la grosse pagaille et fiscale
et le gouvernement a finalement fait son
mea culpa sur ce sujet sensible et
retraités modestes seront exonérés du
paiement de certains impôts locaux en
2015 et en 2016
le geste n'efface pas les marches
arrières entamée par l'exécutif sur
différents dossiers fiscaux ajustements
reculade explications de jules il recule
ajustements apaisement les mots varient
mais la réalité est là
le projet de budget pour 2016 change de
visage chaque jour impôts des retraités
rembourser allocation adulte handicapé
épargné aides au logement préserver le
gouvernement renonce et l'opposition
dénoncent
j'ai vraiment du mal à comprendre qu' on
puisse se retrouver dans cette situation
au delà de la moitié du quinquennat avec
un gouvernement qui est en place déjà
depuis un certain temps la seule
explication rationnelle c'est la panique
électorale prérégionale et
pré-présidentielle ya aucune autre
explication rationnelle à ce qu'on est
en train de vivre pour calmer la grogne
des mères le gouvernement a également
décidé hier de repousser d'un an la
réforme de la
gf la dotation du financement des
communes une décision sage selon les
élus de la majorité je crois qu'il faut
avoir une copie qui soit claire nette et
précise pour tous et c'est à ça que le
gouvernement va s'atteler dans les
prochaines semaines et prochains mois
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté en
2010 est la copie sera je l'espère la
plus parfaite possible sous couvert de
mieux faire entre polémiques et
revirements les changements de posture
de la majorité pourraient bien pourtant
se payer dans les urnes des élections
régionales du mois prochain lors de
toutes parts les critiques à droite
notamment ont fusé pour dénoncer à tour
à tour l'amateurisme et l'improvisation
là la reculade vous vous dites quoi vous
dit que c'est une erreur très importante
une erreur politique très importante
à un mois des élections régionales sur
un sujet majeur pour les français
d'abord ce qui frappe l'esprit c'est que
l'improvisation c'est le fil conducteur
de ce quinquennat on nous avait dit
valls arrive ça va changer du
professionnalisme et c'est mr valls et
dr héros mais c'est à dire que ça
continue ses fausses réformes est vrai
improvisation je veux dire on le voit en
permanence
écoutez aller expliquer ces c'est du
jamais vu allez expliquer aux français
qui ont reçu en taxe d'habitation
rendez-vous dans les perceptions ne
payez pas mais vous avez vu la couille
bon il ya une phénomène d'accélération
de la deûle à bourdin ce taire plutôt
que de rattraper le coup
eh bien on s'enfonce on en rajoute
erreur de communication aussi erreur de
communication mais erreur tout court on
peut pas d'un côté dire la vérité
realpolitik mais la realpolitik parce
qu'il ya des élections de dire le
gouvernement a fait marche arrière
uniquement parce qu'il ya des sections
régionales dans un mois il a eu trois
ans pour modifier cette disposition
d'appel willaey ce que parce que le
gouvernement est ce que le gouvernement
s'est posé la question quand il s'est
agi de supprimer la tva sociale consiste
agit de supprimer la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires il l'a fait bon
eh bien maintenant ils nous accusent
c'est parce que si elle était votée en
tatata je veux dire il avait trois ans
s'ils n'étaient pas d'accord avec cette
mesure les trois ans pour le faire donc
après on assume
or le gouvernement n'assume pas certain
de sa donne le sentiment d'un flottement
non seulement on voit pas la ligne qui a
derrière ferron sais pas quelle est la
politique fiscale
d'un côté on a un président de la
république lui ça va pas augmenter et de
l'autre les français reçoivent leur
feuille d'impôt ça augmente mais on en
connaît pas la ligne et de l'autre il ya
une improvisation parce que même ce
qu'on à vous donner
on le regrette et on ne remonte bien là
mais aussi au sein des services de bercy
on accuse d'avoir commis une faute
qu'est-ce que vous assez facile
attendait trop facile d'isoler passé
merci bien sûr mais moi je n'accepte pas
cette idée les ministres ont bien ce que
dit tout à l'heure un mini ses
responsables de son administration
ça suffit de dire c'est pas moi c'est
administration vers le premier
responsable c'est le ministre qui décide
donc s'il ya eu un problème c'est qu'à
un moment dans le ministère concerné le
ministre concerné n'a pas vu la chose
n'a pas pris la bonne décision
donc ce que je pense c'est que c'est
passé sous les radars et qu' il n'était
pas mécontent de ses rentrées fiscales
puis quand ils sont rendu compte des
dégâts que ça faisait sur le terrain que
100 députés socialistes sont montés au
créneau
si on dit on va faire marche arrière
c'est la pire des formules parce que
quand on parle de baisse de l'autorité
de l'état
ça c'est exactement ça c'est un exemple
qu'y at il de plus important dans un
état que le prélèvement de l'impôt
l'adhésion au fait commun à l'adhésion à
au prélèvement de l'impôt
bon bien quand vous voyez que l'état
branle dans le manche
écoutez c'est un geste de baisse
d'autorité je l'attendais justement je
vous propose de venir va passer au mardi
nicolas sarkozy a fait des propositions
sur la sécurité
une convention aussi elle était
républicain une batterie de mesures en
matière de sécurité le patron des
républicains souhaitent la création
notamment d'un super ministère place
beauvau
les explications de la thalie dit ouah
nicolas sarkozy passe à l'offensive et
endosse l'un de ses costumes préféré
celui de premier flic de france
le président du parti les républicains a
choisi de s'attaquer à la sécurité c'est
quelque chose de central que le
rétablissement de l'autorité de l'état
c'est vraiment la priorité des priorités
et nous avons bien conscience
tout ce que sur la question de la
sécurité il ne peut pas y avoir de faux
semblants on ne peut pas repousser les
responsabilités d'un échec ou d'un
succès sur qui que ce soit d'autre
ça sera notre responsabilité sa
proposition phare la création d'un grand
ministère de la sécurité publique qui
regrouperait policiers gendarmes
douaniers gardiens de prison au sein
d'une même entité
il propose également de recentrer le
travail de la police et de la
gendarmerie sur l'ordre public et le
renseignement
car selon lui les policiers et les
gendarmes sont surchargés de tâches
inutiles
des propositions qui ressemble à un
programme présidentiel
al'approche des primaires à droite
nicolas sarkozy souhaite déjà s'imposer
sur le terrain de la sécurité l'autorité
de l'état c'est le maître mot de la
semaine manuel valls celui se défend
dans une tribune ce vendredi sur
facebook en somme il dit nicolas sarkozy
singes notorité et vous courez après le
front national
on voit bien que le premier ministre qui
cherche d'abord à se démarquer de ce que
fait françois hollande qui est évident
c'est de la communication
on revient que depuis le début du
quinquennat de manière transversale sur
tous les sujets il ya un délitement sur
tous les sujets à une baisse d'autorité
de l'état quand le président de la
république se fait humilier en direct
par une jeune roumaine
c'est un abaissement de l'autorité de
l'état quand la france ne tient pas sa
parole dans un marché vis-à-vis de la
russie
c'est un abaissement d'autoriser l'état
quand on laisse faire des voyous ning
tural non non c'est pas caricatural
quand on laisse faire des voyous
bloqué une autoroute pendant plusieurs
heures sans aucune raison de la terreur
en de la part des forces de l'ordre et
ce vendredi manuel valls est à mwaro est
justement pouvoir les autorités de
l'état et à moirans c'était il ya deux
mois le un mois les événements moyrand
il n'y a pas eu une seule interpellation
je répète vous sage et l'autorité
nicolas sarkozy et singes l'autorité et
court après le front national
mais c'est ce que vous lui répondez à
manuel valls se prend les français
savent ce que je viens de décrire
ils le vivent au quotidien ils voient
bien que l'insécurité augmente
ils voient bien que la place de la
france dans le monde ça fesse ils voient
bien qu'il ya ce besoin de restaurer de
l'autorité moi je considère que le
l'élection de 2017
elle se jouera à travers des projets
politiques autour de deux grands thèmes
le déverrouillage économique du pays la
france est bloquée aujourd'hui elle est
asphyxiée et nous devons la libérer les
deuxièmement c'est justement ce
rétablissement de l'autorité manière
transversale l'autorité c'est à dire la
serbie korité l'âge at-elle mais c'est
c'est c'est dégueulasse ravit au plus
haut niveau
ces ondées chef de l'état ça commence
par le chef de l'état
tu sais ça c'est la politique est mise
en oeuvre en matière de sécurité en
matière de justice qui répertorie tués
selon leur domaine
vous me parlez l'éducation nationale
tout à l'heure quand vous allez
expliquer aux élèves ce qui a été la
tentation de l'actuel gouvernement qu'on
va supprimer les notes que c'est pas
grave d'avoir des on va les remplacer
par des smileys ben je suis pas sûr que
ce soit un symbole un signal positif en
matière d'autorité
les français attendent cela ils
attendent que s'ils voulaient il ya le
sentiment de deux poids deux mesures
d'un état qui ferme les yeux sur les
gros délinquants ou sur des faits
majeurs posés la question qui incarne
l'autorité aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui
je pense que dans le passé les français
sont conscients du fait que sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
il y avait plus d'autorité de manière
transversale à venir c'est l'homme qui
voulait charger en tout cas la politique
qui sera menée par le courant la
sensibilité politique à laquelle
j'appartiens une revient sur le terrain
sécuritaire vous dites c'est 2017 il ya
déjà les tables ils sont là mais il
revient sur les le respect le rôle et la
responsabilité des partis politiques des
candidats aux élections c'est de
répondre aux problèmes aux inquiétudes
des français regardez aujourd'hui quels
sont les interrogations des français
quels sont leurs sujets de prédilection
l'emploi numéro un la sécurité les
questions liées à l'immigration
de manière générale en numéro 2 bon bah
c'est normal qu'à grands partis dits de
gouvernement qui aspirent à gouverner
demain comme les républicains fassent
des propositions dans les deux domaines
alors luc chatel vous avez interpellé le
gouvernement cette semaine à l'assemblée
sur la sphère air cocaïne si l'on peut
dire en tout cas le nom de nicolas
sarkozy s'est retrouvé à surgir dans
cette affaire manuel valls vous a
répondu en lieu et place de santo dira
pour réfuter toute intervention de
l'état dans cette affaire on écoute
pouvez-vous nous garantir monsieur le
premier ministre que dans la sphère dit
d'air cocaïne
tous les clients de la compagnie
aérienne mis en cause ont été traités de
la même manière que savait le président
de la république de la géolocalisation
du chef de l'opposition
dans quelle démocratie vivons nous
alors les français se posent ces
questions monsieur le premier league
nous attendons vos réponses parce que
cette affaire pourrait très vite devenir
une affaire d'état
bien que la sphère dit air cocaïne était
suivi par les services de la
chancellerie il s'avère en revanche que
les actes décidés par le juge
d'instruction de marseille est relatif à
monsieur nicolas sarkozy dans la sphère
dit air cocaïne ne peut en aucun cas été
portée à la connaissance du ministère de
la justice par le parquet général
d'aix-en-provence
gouvernement n'était pas au courant vous
répondez quoi moi je suis monté au
créneau sur ce sujet je très respectueux
de la séparation des pouvoirs les shows
pas du tout dans la surenchère vis à vis
des magistrats comme henri guaino c'est
pas le sujet je vous parle de moi j'ai
pas l'habitude de me monter au créneau
parce que j'ai été scandalisé gérer un
moment où trop c'est trop
d'abord on a vraiment le sentiment là
pour le coup de deux poids deux mesures
dire moi je suis sensible et c'est pour
ça que j'ai interpellé méniscale moment
en le disant matin et vous êtes
j'imagine sensibles à l'égalité des
justiciables devant la loi est ce que
tous les gens qui ont loué cet avion mis
en cause la compagnie aérienne ont eu le
même traitement que nicolas sarkozy
savoir la sécurisation est ce qu'ils ont
été géolocalisés ce qu'on a regardé
leurs facturations détaillées ce qu'on
les a comparées avec les trafiquants de
drogue
est ce que l'on fait sa réponse c'est
dire si ce nom parce que sur ce point là
il n'a pas répondu
deuxièmement il ya des procédures il ya
des règles que dire lorsque nicolas
sarkozy est inscrit au barreau de paris
à la règle c'est que systématiquement le
bâtonnier doit être informée lorsqu'on
utilise les facturations détaillées est
ce qu'il a été
nous n'avons pas rêver steam et cas de
manque de croisade contre nicolas
sarkozy
c'est en tout cas ça donne ce sentiment
et les français mot cgt encore hier dans
ma circonscription et tous ont parlé
avec eux me disent mais ils le rendent
service quelque part lui rendre service
alors quand au troisième sujet ça
démontre l'ambiguïté du système actuel
c'est à dire que la garde des sceaux
nous explique oui oui
et exigé un rapport de la part du
procureur mais je ne savais pas c'est un
peu curieux attendait avec quoi dans ce
rapport on imagine vous imaginez le
procureur général
la ministre ne pouvait pas ne pas savoir
cdpa qualité vous imaginez le procureur
général qui est nommé par le ministre à
qui on demande sur les affaires
sensibles
un rapport vous l'imaginez ne pas
évoquer le fait que l'ancien chef de
l'état est concerné par d une enquête
lancée par la juge d'instruction dont
donc moi je considère que le
gouvernement ne dit pas tout mais dans
ma vérité mais dans n'importe quelle
grande démocratie tenant par omission ce
serait là une excusez moi de ce serait
là une dangla médias ça ferait perdre un
le gouvernement doit s'expliquer dans le
détail pour faire selon la loi une
question certains proches de nicolas
sarkozy estime qu'il ya une forme de
cabinet noir à l'elysée
et je n'en sais rien moi ce que je
regarde c'est l'effet il y à un
acharnement vis-à-vis de nicolas sarkozy
oui je ne suis pas sûr que c'est ça qui
le décourage de sa motivation et que
vis-à-vis des français
ce soit ça qui dut faire face perdre de
la crédibilité bien au contraire on
change de sujet au passo mercredi le
code du travail
le projet était attendu mais beaucoup
s'accordent à dire que c'est un projet à
minima loin du big bang voulue par les
chefs d'entreprise notamment manuel
valls s'en défend et parle de révolution
rym ben ameur le gouvernement se donne
deux ans pour réformer le code du
travail
un code nouvelle version plus lisible et
mieux adapté aux entreprises
mais manuel valls le réaffirme il ne
touchera pas au temps de travail la
loire continuera à garantir des
principes une surprise pour personne
président la république moi même la
ministre nous l'avons rappelé je pense
en particulier à la durée légale de 35
heures par semaine et au paiement
honneur supplémentaire au delà la
nouvelle architecture du code du travail
se fera autour de trois piliers les
droits fondamentaux les droits soumis à
accord collectif et les droits qui
s'applique quand il n'y a pas d'accord
l'objectif donner davantage la main aux
entreprises et aux branches
professionnelles
leur nombre va d'ailleurs être réduit de
7 100 à 200 pour plus d'efficacité
mais dans cette réforme pas de
changement du temps de travail et du
salaire minimum ni du contrat de travail
alors pour l'opposition c'est une
réforme pour rien les vies de tous les
sujets d'une part principale est pas la
hauteur on connaît les sujets à peu
après on peut répondre de façon
différente entre la gauche et la droite
c'est le débat mais il faut bien avoir
le courage d'aborder le temps de travail
mais le gouvernement ne va répondre à
rien de tout cela il va amuser la
galerie qui va d'ailleurs pas rire du
tout et puis après comme toutes les
réformes ça passera ça n'aura rien
changé
les frondeurs eux se disent très
vigilant face à cet assaut contre les
droits du travail que le code du travail
soient simplifiées cissé à droit
constant
parce qu'on peut tous l'entendre mais
que ça doit pas être c'est ça mon
baromètre c'est ça moi la mesure de la
réforme pour moi ça doit pas être une
régression des droits des salariés
robert badinter présidera la commission
chargée de préparer cette réécriture du
code du travail
il devra rendre ses conclusions en deux
mois car le gouvernement veut aller vite
un projet de loi sera présenté début
2016 j'imagine
pas me dire que c'est une révolution ça
je n'en doute pas un seul instant
simplement ce que je voudrais savoir
c'est qu'il ya deux ans avant la mise en
application de cette loi
pas avant 2017 il peut s'en passer des
choses politiquement qu'est ce que vous
faites qui vous arrive au pouvoir
je vais vous dire il ya pire que de ne
pas réformer c'est de faire semblant de
réformer c'est ce que fait manuel valls
le réformisme de manuel valls
il a fait pschitt cette semaine quand
vous dites délibérément tous les experts
savent en matière de droit du travail et
je vous parlais tout à l'heure
d'asphyxier l'économie française
l'économie l'emploi et bloqué dans notre
pays à cause de deux sujets de sujets la
question du temps de travail et de sa
flexibilité et la question de la nature
du contrat de travail et notamment la
rupture du contrat de travail
deux sujets qui par définition le
gouvernement écarte donc on s'occupe du
subalterne
on laisse de côté les deux sujets
principaux comment voulez vous que ça
m'a regard vous ça vous arrive et les 35
heures vous en mettre quoi nous nous
attaquons nous avons fait une convention
il ya quelques semaines sur le droit du
travail nous très clairement nous
considérons qu'il faut que ce soit au
niveau de l'entreprise qu'on discute du
temps de travail qu'on discute de
l'organisation du travail et ça doit
être le niveau de l'entreprise fait dans
l'a pas fait avant de sûr il ya plein de
choses mais si on avait tout fait mais à
l'époque les 35 heures et travailler
plus pour gagner plus on m'appelle je
vais vous dire ça a bien marché les
français s'en souviennent parce qu'il y
avait neuf millions de salariés qui
gagnaient plus équipe car en faisant des
heures supplémentaires mais sans doute
on n'a pas été assez loin mais ici on
avait tout bien fait on aurait été
réellement
donc nous nous avons tiré les
conséquences de tout cela on a beaucoup
réfléchi et nous pensons comme dans les
pays qui ont réussi quand vous avez cinq
pour son taux de chômage en allemagne
pour les 5% de taux chômage en
angleterre ce qu'ils sont
les taux un peu incompressibles là vous
regarde c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
mis plus de flexibilité
oui et ils ont laissé aux entreprises d
des de toutes ces années dans ces pays
là il ya aussi des syndicats qui sont
plus assez donc vous vous porteriez à
ses syndicats la loi je être conscient
oui mais c'est la raison pour laquelle
par exemple nous sommes favorables à des
référendum d'entreprise
il ya des sujets sur lesquels il nous
semble important que ce soit les
salariés qui décidons collectivement on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
représentation des salariés dans
l'entreprise n'est pas assurée
correctement
on voit bien que le délégué du personnel
qui est nommé ça marche pas donc il faut
tout refaire mais nous pensons qu'il
faut remettre à plat et quand on nous
dit c'est une révolution on se moque de
nous alors le sujet n'est pas facile
pour le gouvernement et notamment la
ministre du travail qui a eu un moment
de solitude sur le sujet il était invité
de rmc mercredi écouter on peut leur
nouvelle et comme une fois le cd des
trois fois combien il ya trois ans
jusqu'au nom mais combien
mais la belle connerie ainsi l'emploi
note certes m2 à ce que je faisais
d'aidé combien cdi peut être refait un
cdd peut être qualifié en c1 cdl pardon
parce que je comprends assez d'aidé peut
être requalifié en cdi quand justement
le cadre du recours aux cdd n'a pas été
tellement il peut être renouvelé comme
une fois le cdd il peut être trouver les
plusieurs fois combien de fois maximum
je ne pourrai pas vous le dire votre
réaction faute politique grave peut-elle
rester en place la ministre après cette
phrase si ce qui est affligeant dans
cette séquence c'est qu'on a le
sentiment d'une ministre rosol suivez
moi je vais pas lui en vouloir de ne pas
avoir appris ces fiches c'est pas le
sujet ça peut arriver à tout le monde ça
peut arriver à tout le monde
le sujet c'est pas ça cc c'est la
question la plus importante son
ministère aujourd'hui je vous dit tout à
l'heure la question du contrat de
travail et donc cdd cdi
ces sujets le plus important en plus ce
gouvernement il se trouve qu'il a agi là
dessus et six mois juste avant qu'elle
arrive c'est la question la plus
importante est elle connue elle sépare
donc sous les yeux le fait qu'elle ne
sache pas c'est une chose mais ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire ça ne l'intéresse
pas c'est bien qu'elle sait pas
la question si elle ne connaît pas la
réponse ça veut dire qu'elle s'intéresse
pas aux sujets les trois millions et
demi de chômeurs les cinq millions de
français sans emploi ils savent ce que
c'est qu'un renouvellement de cdd
les chefs d'entreprise à qui une
inspection du travail refuse
régulièrement des renouvellements cd ils
savent que c'est que droit du travail
donc ça veut dire que certes elle est
ministre depuis un mois mais dans ce
mois qui vient de s'écouler
elle ne s'est pas encore mis à la place
de ceux qu'elle est censée servir fait
la mise c'est difficile de devient vite
vous demander non moi je laisserais dans
cette logique si vous décidez mai mais
imaginez le message qu'on envoie aux 5
millions de sans emploi c'est genre bah
écoutez moi ça fait un mois que j'y suis
je me suis même pas occupé de l'autre
car je ne sais même pas comment ça
marche là tu veux dire moi je suis
devenu ministre l'éducation nationale
est tout seul c'était pas ma spécialité
d'une crise nationale donc je suis
arrivé qu est-ce que qu'est-ce que je ne
prends pas jeu en exemple mais je
compare moi je suis arrivé au mois de
juin bas pendant deux mois je me suis
caché je n'ai pas couru les plateaux de
télévision j'ai travaillé
c'est un concept minutes moi j'aimerais
m'en fasse oui je pense que dans des
missions difficiles où vous êtes à la
fois aussi très technique et vous êtes
très exposé voilà et j'avais un rendez
vous annuel qui est très important de
les éduquer choisi la conférence de
presse de rentrée le 1er septembre vous
avez 70 journalistes c'est un peu le
grand oral bon ben voilà donc vous pour
vous mais qui arrive au mieux se cacher
un moment et et c'est le reflet de ce
gouvernement
trop de com tu l'action politique
axiome autre temps fort mercredi luc
chatel au dossier air france députés et
sénateurs ont auditionné le pdg de la
compagnie et les syndicats il s'agissait
d'évoquer les plans sociaux prévus pour
sauver la compagnie l'ambiance était
tendue comme l'a constaté
germa andrieu audition sous tension du
pdg d'air france à l'assemblée à quinze
jours d'une journée de mobilisation
annoncée par l'intersyndicale compagnies
aériennes frédéric gagey a immédiatement
démenti l'existence d'un plan b en cours
avec la suppression de près de 3000
postes
il n'y a jamais eu de liste déjà envoyé
ou de courriers envoyés
salariés jeu ces petits bleus quitté
l'entreprise un sable se montrent pas ça
qui s'est passé il n'ya pour pour
l'instant naturellement aucun plan de
départs involontaires qui aurait été
engagé par la compagnie sinon nous le
saurions aucun plan b avec des départs
involontaires pour le moment mais une
réduction des effectifs
incontournable pour rendre l'entreprise
plus compétitive côté syndicats on
souhaite plus de clarté sur le plan
économique nous sommes prêts à le
relever le défi de la compétitivité de
l'entreprise
mais pas à n'importe quel prix ceux ci
ont fait les efforts qui ne servent à
rien c'est comme si on montait à
l'échafaud et compass agence pas se
couper un bras
mais c'est pas notre jeu prochaine étape
le 19 novembre jour de la mobilisation
générale et du prochain comité central
de l'entreprise
à gauche comme à droite on espère
surtout le retour du dialogue social les
organisations de salariés l instant
disent tous la même chose et tous
métiers confondus et toutes
organisations syndicales confondues
ils attendent un plan stratégique de
développement de la part des dirigeants
de l'entreprise
ils attendent un vrai dialogue social et
ils attendent que l'état joue pleinement
son rôle elle le dialogue va être
difficile parce que moi j'estime que
quand on veut dialoguer et qu'on veut un
dialogue social qui soit apaisée il faut
déjà partagé à la fois le diagnostic de
la situation
partager les objectifs et là on n'y est
pas encore quelle que soit l'issue du 19
novembre
les négociations sont programmées
jusqu'à mi janvier pour trouver un
nouvel accord sur le plan d'économies
lors de cette audition de l'audition en
tout cas à l'assemblée l'intersyndicale
a mis en cause le l'état en estimant
qu'il n'a pas bien joué son rôle
d'actionnaire qu'est ce que vous dites
vous ce qu'il ya eu une faille de l'état
ça c'est vrai mais c'est pas nouveau il
ya quelques mois d'abord moi je suis
pour au maximum des privatisations je
pense que l'état
est encore trop présent dans des
participations de grandes entreprises
devraient se désengager deuxièmement et
et l'état n'est pas un bon actionnaire
la vérité alors ensuite selon les
gouvernements c'est plus ou moins vrai
il se trouve qu'il ya moins d'un an le
gouvernement a joué un trouble fête sur
le premier conflit qui a été celui de
transavia où il a été annoncé en grande
pompe le retrait du plan et autres alors
que c'était stratégiquement très
important pour la compagnie qui a perdu
entre nous plus de 500 millions d'euros
à cause de ce conflit
deuxièmement sur ce conflit on voit bien
qu'il a joué les atermoiements ont
relevé qu'il ya deux lignes au sein du
gouvernement entre d'un côté le
ministère de tutelle sur le plan
économique et mathieu macron qui
encourage les entreprises à se réformer
et puis de l'autre la ministre des
transports qui était assez discrète au
début en général quand lé conflit comme
ça et souvent assez discrète elle envoie
plutôt son secrétaire d'état aux
transports l'aco a sorti du bois pour
faire volte-face et tu tirer une balle
dans le dos de d'air france ça peut pas
marcher
c'est quand vous avez un plan aussi
difficile donc c'est là vous avez un
historique est historique de la gestion
sociale qui est difficile chez air
france vous avez besoin d'un actionnaire
qui vous accompagnent qui à vos côtés
qui partagent vos orientations
si c'est pas le cas écoutez à ce moment
là c'est à l'actionnaire de décider mais
l'actionnaire il doit être avec la le
management avec la direction générale il
doit être en phase sur les objectifs
sinon ça peut pas marcher
alors je dis la question du droit de
vote des étrangers ressurgi dans le
débat
si nous ne pouvons pas mettre en oeuvre
le droit de vote des résidents étrangers
alors il ne faut pas le proposer
paroles de manuel valls le premier
ministre s'exprimait devant des
étudiants de sciences po à paris
c'était pourtant une revendication forte
d'une partie de l'électorat et d'élus de
gauche écouter ce n'est pas possible
politiquement ce n'est pas possible
constitutionnellement et parce que je ne
pense pas que ce soit une priorité je
l'avais dit il ya trois ans avait
provoqué un scandale on avait dit
abandon d'une promesse mais ces deux
promesses de toute façon à ne pas pas
mises en oeuvre et je suis convaincu
qu'elle ne sera pas reproposer à la
prochaine élection présidentielle parce
qu'elle temps inutilement parce que ça
n'est plus le sujet je pense que c'est
une faute que les députés n'est pas à
délibérer sur le sujet je partage avec
lui le fait que eux
mathématiquement nous n'aurions pas eu
la majorité des trois cinquièmes au
parlement pour mettre en place ce droit
top parce que les parlementaires de
droite et ce près du centre ils sont
opposés auraient voté contre
je considère néanmoins qu'il aurait
fallu que l'on débatte à l'assemblée
nationale et qu'on prouve qu'elles sont
tout simplement ceux qui y sont
favorables mais en appuyant sur le
bouton de vote
je vous présente mon cher à ses autres
partenaires d'escale vous que l'on fait
nous interroger dans deux petites
secondes d'abord sur le fond cette fois
sur le vote des étrangers
vous devriez applaudir la gauche
aujourd'hui
finalement ils ne font pas je veux dire
de ça m'inspire de réflexion ce que j'ai
un devoir d'abord serpent de mer
chaque élection à chaque fois que la
gauche sans que une élection va lui
échapper et que le front national est
aux ailes nous balance elle balance aux
français ce chiffon rouge de l'élection
et les hercules oui ok mais le débat est
mis sur la table
deuxième réflexion ce qui est
extraordinaire la séquence qu'on vient
de voir illustre assez bien ce que je
décrivais au début notre émission en
disant que à qui s'adresse manuel valls
quand il dit
attendez quand on sait qu'on peut pas le
mettre en oeuvre il faut pas en parler à
qui s'adresse votre sympathie qui a
parlé qui a mis sur la table le droit de
vote aux élections locales
françois hollande en 2012 cette carte
dont claire au niveau de l'autorité de
l'état
mais non mais ça veut dire que manuel
valls adressé à françois hollande donc
devant les français il règle ses comptes
avec le président de la république donc
au plus haut niveau c'est on sait très
bien que la paralysie de ce gouvernement
elle est d'abord due à un hiatus entre
deux lignes politiques qui sont pas
compatibles à notre dame des landes
ce qui est le cas canarde les forces de
l'ordre c'est ce qu'ils ont fait hier
françois hollande
voilà bon c'est ça la vérité et c'est
manuel valls qui s'est manuel valls qui
envoie les crs
donc voilà vous avez d'un côté les
soutiens de françois hollande du
discours du bourget qui envoie des cv
cela votre et de l'autre manuel valls
qui est le chef des crs voilà bah c'est
ça la gauche aujourd'hui difficile pour
vous trouvez votre adversaire c'est
manuel valls ou françois hollande
mais nous écouter d'abord avant de nous
préoccuper nos adversaires on s'occupe
de notre projet de programme ce ne sont
pas nos hôtes nous sommes en campagne
pour les élections régionales
c'est un enjeu très important parce que
après la reconquête des départements la
reconquête des villes
le basculement du sénat nous avons une
dernière échéance locales et nous
souhaitons un basculement massif des
régions james est à vous dans un instant
la loupe du skate bonjour luc chatel
bonjour voit de plus en plus défendre
nicolas sarkozy a encore quelques
minutes sur le dossier air cocaïne êtes
son conseiller politique
quel rôle allez vous jouer dans les mois
à venir alors que la bataille pour la
primaire va s'intensifier moi je
souhaite tout simplement que notre
famille gagne les élections de 2017 est
calé à redresser ce pays
voilà donc c'est ça qui m'intéresse le
reste ne m'intéresse pas et je souhaite
que nous abordions cette période qui va
pas être simple parce que après les
régionales vous allez voir les primaires
la campagne on sait ce que c'est
justement sur les prix nous l'abordions
avec sérénité avec force sur les mois
j'ai j'ai essayé des deux dernières
années d'être utile à ma famille
politique
j'en étais secrétaire général dans des
moments très difficiles où notre moment
a failli disparaître ou il y avait des
tensions comme n'y avait jamais eu
depuis 25 ou 30 ans voilà donc moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que à la fin on
fasse jouer le débat sur les primaires
je pense que c'est nécessaire que chacun
puisse s'exprimer
iliad est sensible
différentes il ya des talents différents
mais il ya beaucoup de talents ya
beaucoup d'idées
donc il faut bien oui mais vaut mieux le
trot que le passé exemple la bataille
s'intensifie j'observe un truc c'est
qu'il ya quelques mois on expliquer
qu'on n'avait pas d'idées on n'avait pas
de projet et on faisait que de la
politique politicienne aujourd'hui on
nous explique qu'à trop de mesures dans
le projet sur la sécurité
est-ce qu'il ya pas encore un peu de
politique politicienne demain samedi il
ya un conseil national des républicains
à la salle de la mutualité un grand
discours nicolas sarkozy est attendu
il y aura des absents très remarqué je
parle évidemment de françois fillon
alain juppé bruno le maire ne seront pas
là et ce qu'ils ont ils voient un
boycott vis-à-vis nicolas sarkozy
sincèrement je ne pense pas ils sont
présents régulièrement au bureau
politique qui prime ils n'étaient pas là
mardi lors de la matinée de travail sur
la sécurité mais italienne deux
événements majeurs du parti auquel
détenant ne participe pas demandé leur
dire moi je suis du suis pas là mais
vous êtes à l'intérieur comme envoûté
les choses de l'intérieur non moi je
trouve ça dommage ça vous le dis
franchement non mais je trouve ça
dommage pourquoi castro toi c'est quoi
l'objet du conseil national de samedi
c'est d'investir nos candidats aux
élections régionales dont candidats aux
élections régionales ils sont pas en
train de choisir le candidat à la
primaire il s'est pas les militants de
des républicains qui ont choisir quant à
imprimer recéler français sympathisants
de droite et du centre donc c'est un
rendez vous important pour nos candidats
ils vont aller aux élections
ils attendent quoi nos candidats nos
électeurs ils attendent quoi c'est qu'on
montre qu'on est rassemblée qu'on est
unis
ensuite bien sûr il ya des je suis pas
naïf luc chatel ya des sensibilités
différentes
on n'est pas d'accord sur tout sarkozy a
proposé des choses mardi que je paie ou
fillon avec lesquels ils sont pas
forcément d'accord ok c'est la politique
mais là on est derrière nos candidats
aux régionales c'est un rendez vous
important
ben moi je vous savez trop tôt s'ils
peuvent encore changer d'avis je trouve
ça bien qu'il vienne vous dites dommage
est-ce que c'est pas une faute politique
de laisser nicolas sarkozy tout seul sur
l'autoroute comme ça c'est votre
interprétation mais nicolas sarkozy
il avance voilà il a été élu par les
militants de l'ump à l'époque pour
redresser le parti il à apaiser la
situation il rassemble il engrange des
succès électoraux et il prépare le
projet jan vous avez fait sens que je
revienne phrase que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure qui m'a interpellé si on avait
tout bien fait lors du précédent
quinquennat on aurait été réélu est ce
que justement le fait que nicolas
sarkozy était battu en 2012 n'est pas un
handicap majeur en vue d'une possible
réélection en 2017
ça c'est une question que vous ne
poserez le moment c'est vous qui l'avez
abordé tout à l'heure oui non ma job
n'est pas abordée de métier j'ai abordé
le passé oui dans le débat précédent et
écoutez je serais si aujourd'hui vous
commencez à dire aux français mais on a
tout ce qu'on a fait était formidable
moi je ne fais pas plus la politique
comme ça c'est très possible
alors ça exaspère les français voilà
donc oui on n'a pas fait des choses bien
mais moi je vous dis j'ai pas fait que
des choses bien quand j'étais ministre a
oui il ya trois croyable incroyable
alors très rapidement
pour terminer cette séquence je veux
vous faire réagir pardon à trois
séquences de communication politique de
cette semaine la première c'était la
semaine dernière françois hollande chez
l'habitant
bfmtv a révélé que la rencontre chez
lucette qui est désormais très connu
avait été montée de toute pièce est ce
qu'il s'agit
voilà dsk est ce que françois hollande
s'est piégé lui-même dans sa propre
bowling communication j'ai trouvé ça
pathétique
pourquoi que françois hollande voit des
entre guillemets vrais français est très
bien voilà mais à ce moment là qu'il les
reçoive à l'elysée en toute discrétion
ce qui nous explique qu'il a livré une
des sécurités de macha c'est pas quand
le présent attendait qui les invite à
l'elysée bon ensuite il sera entendu ce
justifié on nous expliquera non mais ce
n'était pas une opération de
communication
ah oui donc c'est passé en ligne sur
tous les réseaux sociaux sur les médias
il y avait cette pauvre lucette
avec 17 ministres et députés autour
d'elle dans sa salle à manger étriqué
affligeant deuxième séquence une chanson
de fresnes à cuillé qui est tête de
liste dans le pas de calais contre
marine le pen on écoute un petit extrait
mais j'ai honte
quand
est ce que c'est de la bonne
communication
à titre personnel je ne pense pas voilà
je veux dire il nous est arrivé
républicains de faire ce genre de choses
je pense que je pense que à chaque fois
que les responsables politiques se
mettent en scène il se trompe
nous ne sommes pas des stars c'est pas
vrai les français qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent c'est qu'on réponde à leurs
problèmes
voilà je trouve pas que s'agrandisse je
parle même pas de frédéric cuvillier le
candidat les candidats la politique de
manière générale dernière séquence
rapidement le clip diffusé par le
ministère de l'éducation cette semaine
contre le harcèlement scolaire c'est un
sujet très sérieux on en regarde un
extrait
tu m'aimes pas lire débile des larmes de
la classe baptiste baptiste est avec
nous
alors les syndicats d'enseignants sont
montés monté au créneau pour ce plan
d'une image caricaturale des enseignants
vous allaitez anciens ministres
éducation vous êtes exprimé d'ailleurs
sur cette question du harcèlement
scolaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
polémique est ce qu'elle est justifiée
je me suis pas exprimé c'est moi qui ai
lancé qui était le premier ministre a
lancé la politique de lutte contre le
harcèlement à l'école donc j'adhère
complètement à cette campagne qui est
exactement dans l'esprit des clips que
j'avais moi même lancée en 2011 voilà le
les élucubrations des enseignants j'y
suis habitué il faut des mains mais bien
sûr si voulez on a besoin de lutter
contre l'omerta c'est le harcèlement à
l'école c'est 10 % des élèves et
pourquoi j'ai pour vous pourquoi j'ai
agi parce que j'ai été bouleversé par
des témoignages de parents qui sont venu
m'expliquer me parler ce qui arrivait à
leurs enfants
ça peut pas vous laisser indifférent
voilà donc les corporatismes dans ces
cas là c'est franchement déplacé place
merci merci du téléphone et on va passer
au plus de l'hebdo c'est une question
récurrente dans la vie politique est ce
que vous savez ce que veut dire le front
républicain vous posera évidemment la
question dans un instant mais regardez
c'est le micro trop tard d'alexandre
d'armes front républicain anti mais ça
veut dire quoi exactement je sais pas
moi je vais demander aux parlementaires
ou ministres de la république
mais moi je vais vous parler d'un sujet
qui a fait une erreur en place c'est
vrai c'est quoi mon bonheur c'est le
front républicain
c'est manuel valls on a parlé crois pas
que d'utiliser le mot ici on ne parle
que de ça parlera pas du reste donc
voilà donc nous on va débuter une
campagne électorale n'est pas fini c'est
un beau coup de corne principal parti de
la droite quand même ce qu'on
républicain on va faire alliance pour
les élections régionales
c'est vrai public and her shoes de kia
républicain c'est clair pour vous le
front républicain
ce que j'ai compris ça veut dire qu'il
faut que les républicains en
l'occurrence et les socialistes fassent
front commun devant le front national
c'est par rapport au secours républicain
que tout mon appel le front républicain
peut pas répondre dans le couloir si les
républicains sont vraiment républicain
su socialistes sont conformes à leurs
histoires leurs traditions oui ils
savent faire la différence entre
l'extrême droite et la droite
chacun court dans son couloir c'est
quand même ce qui est venu à faire
d'accord je vais être fortement majorité
en sera du 1er tour vous verrez d'accord
avant le parti républicain ce qu'on veut
c'est arrivé numéro un numéro deux dans
toutes les régions et on parlait quoi
parce que j'en parle c'est comme ça au
sérieux
la politique c'est pas simplement rigolo
comme on a de temps en temps dans les
émissions de télévision ou les gens son
clown merci nous les arrêtons tout cas
merci beaucoup avait prévenu qu'une
question pour l'effet barcelone qui se
serait arrêté pour toi et pour vous luc
chatel c'est quoi le front républicain
c'est tous des à l'est républicain pour
les régionales un peu facile quand même
c'est que je te dis ça peut exister
non non c'est pour fusionner il faut
être d'accord sur un projet sur les
orientations sur l'essentiel j'ai pas eu
santé animale pour vous non quand vous
regardez le
il ya des différences c'est aux
électeurs de choisir eh bien merci luc
chatel ce sera le mot de la fin merci
d'avoir été là bien au parlement et le
dos pour son ton version prochaine ktm
bonne semaine à tous